[MUSIC PLAYING]
ASHLEY CHANG: How
you doing, Daron?
DARON ROBERTS: Doing well.
It's good to be here.
I left Austin, it
was 75 degrees.
ASHLEY CHANG: And we're
even less than 57,
the opposite, right?
DARON ROBERTS: But it's good.
It's good.
I brought scarves, I got
hats, all the things.
ASHLEY CHANG: You
got a Google beanie.
DARON ROBERTS: Beanies, yes.
I got a Google beanie.
ASHLEY CHANG: We have supplied
him with some Google swag.
So we are really excited to
have you here today, Daron.
DARON ROBERTS: I'm
glad to be here.
Thank you for having me.
ASHLEY CHANG: So my
name is Ashley Chang,
and today, I'm just so excited
to introduce all of you
to Daron K. Roberts.
Daron has an amazing story.
It's not conventional
in any means.
Daron is a Harvard
Law School grad
turned NFL coach turned
best selling author.
And now, he is a lecturer at the
University of Texas at Austin,
where he actually started
a center for sports
leadership and innovation.
He's the founding
director there.
DARON ROBERTS:
Yes, it's been fun.
And I chase five little people,
ages seven to seven months.
This is great.
I'm glad to be here.
This is a break from home.
It's good.
ASHLEY CHANG: Good.
So we'll talk about a
lot of things today.
We'll talk about his
book, "Call an Audible."
Congratulations on your book.
Amazon-- it was one of their
number one new releases.
Sports Illustrated said this is
one of the best sports business
books of 2017.
No big deal, right?
DARON ROBERTS: It's been fun.
It was one of those things--
I don't know if people are like
me, where you have this Google
Doc, and it's been living for
five to six years with ideas.
And that was where I
was with this book.
I had been working on an
introduction for four years.
And I finally just woke up one
morning and told my wife, OK.
Six days a week,
two hours a day,
I'm going to write
from 3:30 to 5:30.
I'm going to go to
the same coffee shop,
turn off the Wi-Fi, and just go.
And she's like, Godspeed.
And we did it, and it was funny.
ASHLEY CHANG: Here it is.
DARON ROBERTS: Here it is.
It's actually tangible.
ASHLEY CHANG: Amazing.
And I have one, too.
It's my own special copy.
I love it.
DARON ROBERTS: Do you read it
before you go to bed at night?
ASHLEY CHANG: I do.
Well, I've already read it.
And I'll read it again
maybe after this talk.
DARON ROBERTS: And you can buy
more copies if you need to.
ASHLEY CHANG: OK so I
can't go through you?
I got to go through Amazon?
DARON ROBERTS: Better
to go through me.
Yeah, a better take.
I got five college tuitions.
ASHLEY CHANG: Gotcha.
We have to support the family.
I understand.
So Daron, you've done
a lot, but I also
want to mention
in his free time,
Daron also started and leads a
nonprofit football camp for--
is it high school students?
DARON ROBERTS: High
school students.
So these are not blue
chip athletes, right?
These are high school, try hard,
I love football Daron types.
And we take them for a week--
40 high school students.
And in the morning it's yoga
and meditation and reflection,
and then we play football
for about 2 and 1/2 hours.
Then it's three
hours of ACT prep.
And we built a
curriculum where we
have taken the ACT math
section and translated it
into football examples.
So we teach geometry and
algebra using a football field
as a grid.
And then at night,
we have a series
of two workshops--
so social media
etiquette, dress etiquette,
how to write thank you notes.
And it's been a
wonderful program.
We've had 500 kids come
through in the last nine years.
ASHLEY CHANG: That's phenomenal.
It's really nice
to know that you
are giving back to the community
and teaching practical skills,
right?
Yes, the academic piece, but
also, what should you wear?
How can you present
yourself in a way that
is the best reflection of you?
DARON ROBERTS: The social
media class-- oh, geez.
So part of the
application process
is they have to list their
social media handles.
And then we have
a team of people
who we scrub all of
their handles, platforms,
and take screenshots of the
good, the bad, and the ugly.
And they don't
know what's coming.
And so on day four, I
kind of just walk up.
And I'll have this dummy
slide up about, hey,
how to make a speech.
And then slide two
will be someone's post
where it's nothing but
profanity and drinking a beer.
Hey, who is this?
And everyone's embarrassed.
Oh my gosh, I can't
believe he would do that.
I say, now, hold on.
There are 2 billion
people out there
on some form of social media.
Why would you be embarrassed?
And so we start there
and then kind of work
through how they can
present a good image online.
ASHLEY CHANG: That's great.
I think with technology
and with all social media,
it's so easy to just write
something or post something.
But if you were to
actually sit in a stage
and have the whole
world, maybe you
would say that maybe your
students or other folks
wouldn't actually
post that much.
DARON ROBERTS: Yeah.
And all the research right
now is showing that so much
of what we do online
is subconscious.
So they're showing
people tweets, posts
that they've liked or
shared and asking them
if they recognize them.
And the rate's around 25%.
So you're just scrolling,
scrolling, scrolling,
like here, heart here,
heart there, and it becomes
sort of stream of consciousness.
And so really for
us, we're trying
to get the students to be more
intentional and deliberate
about their move.
So when you hit
the heart button,
we say for employers
or other schools,
that is an endorsement.
So you need to think about, do I
want to cosign on this message?
ASHLEY CHANG: And this is
all in his free time, right?
So in addition to the
4th and 1 football camp,
Daron also leads a
industry leading podcast.
And he's also the chief
of the Donut Council,
which is probably going to be
my favorite part of this talk.
And We'll tell you a little
bit more about that later.
And like I mentioned
in some of the comms
that you might have
seen before, we will--
I've promised them,
if it's OK with you--
we will talk about Kevin Durant.
And we will talk about
donuts, which you love.
DARON ROBERTS:
Durant and donuts.
I can do that.
ASHLEY CHANG: Good.
done.
Is that all right with you all?
OK, sounds good.
So why don't we just start
at the beginning, OK?
You're Texas born and raised.
DARON ROBERTS: Yes.
ASHLEY CHANG: And when
you were a teenager, kid,
what were your dreams?
DARON ROBERTS: So fifth
generation east Texan
would sit at-- my dad showed me
this map of this Panola County
where he's from, and it was
a census tract from 1870.
And there's a plot of land that
has 153 acres and the name Bill
Roberts, and it's 1870, right?
So he points to the map.
He points to me.
And he says, this is why you
will never have any excuses.
I'm like, what the
hell's he talking about?
I don't know.
And then I find out that
my great great grandfather
finds a way to get 153 acres
in a county that sent troops
to the Confederacy.
How does a black man in 1870--
how do you do that?
And so my last
book will be this.
I want to present three
different scenarios
in a fictional way of
what could have happened.
But that sort of set
the stage for me of,
OK, I got to pull the
top off of my goals.
And so I wanted to be the
governor of Texas by 40.
I turned 40 in November.
ASHLEY CHANG: You
can adjust to 41.
DARON ROBERTS: I took
a wrong turn somewhere.
Yeah, kind of push it out.
I wanted to be the
governor, and so I
thought that was undergrad,
government pre-law, law school,
practice somewhere,
run for Congress--
a very linear if A then B,
if B then C. And now my life
is just like a sketch pad.
ASHLEY CHANG: Well, I love it.
I think it's just a
different direction.
OK, so let's talk about law.
So you wanted to
go to law school.
Why law school?
Was it because you
wanted to be governor?
And then I know you kind
of talked about Harvard.
There was something
about that school
that really drew you there.
DARON ROBERTS: Yeah.
Gregory Peck had a
lot to do with it.
If I think about the
imagery that really
made me think about law
school, "To Kill a Mockingbird"
comes to mind.
And scenes where
this powerful figure
being able to influence
the community around him--
that was one image
that stood out for me.
And then my dad bought a book.
It was a biography
of Thurgood Marshall.
I just remember
this image of him
standing on the steps
of the Supreme Court
after Brown v. Board
and thinking to myself,
I want to be like that guy.
And so everything was
channeled towards law school.
And I'm at the
University of Texas.
I'm student body president.
I had great grades.
I'm like, I'm just
going to walk in.
ASHLEY CHANG: It's
going to be easy, right?
DARON ROBERTS: It's
going to be easy.
They're going to be like,
oh, we've been waiting
for you for the last 18 years.
ASHLEY CHANG: Welcome, Daron.
DARON ROBERTS: Welcome, welcome.
Finally, right?
And I get the letter back,
and it's the old wait list.
So it's, we like you,
we like some more people
a lot more than you.
ASHLEY CHANG: And you're
like, how is this possible?
DARON ROBERTS: In the event
that all of them tell us no,
we may call you back.
But if you have better
options, don't wait for us.
ASHLEY CHANG: I feel like
that's worse than a no.
DARON ROBERTS: Yes it is.
It is.
Because it's like you're close.
It's funny.
At the time, I thought
I wanted the no.
But in retrospect, I think the
wait list was probably better,
because there's this
little glimmer of hope
that I could somehow alter
the situation in some way.
But I got listed
four years in a row.
So Gwen Robertson,
my mom's, like,
just do something
with your life.
I worked on the Hill.
I went to the Kennedy School.
And then the fourth
year, I got in.
ASHLEY CHANG: And
was it everything
you imagined and more?
DARON ROBERTS: It was worse.
It was worse.
It was a hell.
It was.
ASHLEY CHANG: Good, I like this.
DARON ROBERTS: I
was about to lie.
I was about to
blatantly lie to myself.
I'm like, no, it was bad.
It's an interesting
place, right?
So you have 550 students come
into a class, and everyone's so
high strung.
You've got the folks who are
just fresh out of undergrad,
so they're going berserk.
Every single second of the day,
the gunners on the front row.
I had worked for a while,
so I was kind of chill.
I had to make sure
I got the Dunkin'
Donuts before going into class.
ASHLEY CHANG: Priorities.
DARON ROBERTS:
Priorities, priorities.
But it was fun.
I think I enjoy
being challenged.
And I did like the grind
of the 1L first year.
In the library, you kind
of stink a little bit.
You're reading stuff,
you're falling asleep.
I liked that piece of it.
But I knew there was something
else I should probably
be doing with life.
ASHLEY CHANG: And so this
talk is all about risks.
And your story in itself
is really interesting--
to pivot so many
different times.
And I'd like to know--
it was your summer
internship, right?
Your first summer
internship in law school--
tell us about that
experience and how you felt.
DARON ROBERTS: So I worked at
name ampersand name, name, name
in DC.
And I remember the
first day walking
in working my way to my office
and recognizing the fact
that no one had smiled--
receptionist, insert
first year associate,
insert 30 year partner.
I thought, wow, OK.
Maybe it's just a rough time.
The was the summer.
And the highlight-- first
day, this first year associate
comes in.
Hey, man, what are
you doing for lunch?
I'm like, I don't
have any plans.
You're going with me, right?
ASHLEY CHANG: You're
like, this guy's nice.
DARON ROBERTS: It's great.
We go to lunch.
He's not talking to me.
It's 2006, he was on a
BlackBerry, you know.
And I'm like, hey,
man, how's it going?
We're talking.
He's like, I just love it
when you summers get here,
because we get our
lunches comped.
ASHLEY CHANG: Oh my gosh.
So he didn't--
DARON ROBERTS: It's recruiting.
ASHLEY CHANG: He wanted you
there not necessarily to talk
to you but to eat the lunch.
DARON ROBERTS: Yes.
So then I thought, wow.
The highlight of
this grown man's life
is a comped summer intern lunch?
ASHLEY CHANG: You're like, this
is not really what I thought.
DARON ROBERTS: This is not.
So I remember going back to
law school, thinking, OK.
There's probably something else.
And that's when my
buddy the next year
calls me to go to
work a football camp.
And we were both
try hard players.
There were no teams beating
down our door in high school
saying, come play for us.
But he was a football
coach-- a high school coach.
And he said, hey, come to the
South Carolina football camp.
So I get there, and
they need someone
to fill in for a coach
who hadn't shown up.
So I'm thinking, I
played Texas football.
I know what's going on.
So I raised my hand,
and I'm like, yo.
Where do you coach?
I'm like, Mount
Pleasant High School.
He's like, all right,
Mount Pleasant High School.
You have group six.
Yes sir.
I'm like, what the
hell's he talking about?
Group six was 60
sixth graders, none
of whom had any athletic
talent whatsoever.
Mamas had taken them to
academy to get swooshes,
and they were
protecting the house.
And they were doing
it and could not back
pedal the length of
this stage, and they
had a coach who couldn't coach.
Best 72 hours my life.
there are these
very brief moments
in football where
socioeconomic status goes
out the window, what side
of town you live, religion.
You're just trying to get
11 people on the same page.
And I recognized
for me, that became
a new form of public service.
So I started the journey
to try to become a coach.
ASHLEY CHANG: So I
think many of us--
I'm sure you might agree--
often times, we have
inklings to do things.
We see certain passions.
But what was it that
got you from feeling
that you love this thing
and shoving it away as like,
OK, that was a great
72 hour vacation,
and then turning it
into something tangible
and deciding you wanted
to coach football?
DARON ROBERTS: So
Brene Brown says--
she says, emotions are data.
And I could not get away
from the feeling in my gut.
Even when I left the camp,
I go back to Cambridge,
it was in my mind.
It was this uneasy
feeling in my stomach.
And I've also just
been of the belief--
my dad's a Baptist minister.
So if you walk into the
Mount Olive Baptist Church
on a Sunday at 12:24
PM, Kurt Roberts
is going to be
standing up saying,
you don't know when
you're going to die.
You better get right with Jesus.
And I think hearing
that for so long--
just the delicate
nature of mortality.
You don't know.
We assume so much.
I've always thought, let me try
to pull these things that I'm
thinking about putting
off into the distance.
Let me pull them into
the present tense,
because I don't know if I
get to retirement, right?
And people are like,
oh, just go practice,
and then you can do that
sort of as a retirement job.
I'm like, who says I get
to retirement, right?
So from that step,
I went into Excel--
which, if this was 2018, I
would have gone into Sheets.
And I went through
every team in the NFL,
and I found their address
and every coach on staff.
And I went through every bio and
tried to find some connection.
Are you from Texas?
Then you're getting
a letter from me.
Did you study
government in undergrad?
You're getting a letter from me.
And I just wrote multiple
letters to every team
in the NFL.
ASHLEY CHANG: So this is one of
my favorite parts of this book,
and I'm going to read a
piece of one of the letters.
Dear Coach, and you sounded
exactly like this, right?
DARON ROBERTS: Yes, exactly.
ASHLEY CHANG: Dear Coach.
I am a third year student
at Harvard Law School,
and I want to become
a football coach.
After just three days of
working as a volunteer coach,
I realized that changing the
life trajectories of young men
can be fulfilled by coaching a
sport that I fell in love first
in high school.
I understand that you receive
countless letters each year,
but I promise I will work
harder than anybody else you are
considering for this position.
And then you went
down, and you said
some other wonderful things.
And then ended with,
please just consider me
for any entry level position
you may have available.
So what?
You sent this out to
many, many, many people.
DARON ROBERTS: Yes.
My last name wasn't Belichick,
and I didn't have any buddies.
There was no in.
So for me, I knew the only
way that I could break in
would be to start at not
even the bottom, below
the totem pole.
ASHLEY CHANG: So what happened?
You sent this, and--
DARON ROBERTS: I sent this,
and I got 31 rejections.
So Belichick, Tomlin, you
name it, going down the list.
John Fox-- all these
teams are saying no.
And it gets to a point
where this is April.
This is two months
before I'm graduating.
And my classmates are
going to the Supreme
Court, and the White House, and
insert banking, I bank here.
And I'm just waiting on one yes.
And I finally get a
call one day from a guy
named Herm Edwards, who was a
Kansas City Chiefs head coach.
And he's like, hey,
this is Herm Edwards.
I need to talk
with Daron Roberts.
So I think it's a prank.
And I'm about to
say something that
was not going to get me a job.
I'm like, yes, sir?
He said, hey.
I don't open my mail.
My secretary put this
letter on my desk.
What's wrong with you?
So I said, well, nothing
that's been documented.
I work this camp.
He's like, yeah, whatever.
OK, here's the deal.
He's like, take out
a pen and paper.
I take out the pen.
Training camp intern.
I'm like, yes.
No pay-- it gets better-- no
benefits, and then he says,
18 hour days.
So I'm going back
to employment law.
I'm like, this has got to
be some kind of a claim.
I'm like, 18 hour days?
He goes, are you in?
And this three seconds
sort of window--
and I knew I couldn't ask for
any clarifying information.
I said yes.
He's like, OK.
Graduate from law school,
get here, hangs the phone up.
So I drove June 6 from
Cambridge, Massachusetts
to Kansas City, Missouri
in a 2002 Chevy Tahoe
that I still own,
because I'm cheap.
It's also why I'm a
Planet Fitness member.
ASHLEY CHANG: And [INAUDIBLE].
DARON ROBERTS: Yes.
ASHLEY CHANG: We talked
about that a great deal.
DARON ROBERTS: Yes.
And I was the grunt.
I didn't sign a piece
of paper in six months.
If you were to google Daron
Roberts Kansas City Chiefs
in 2007, nothing would come up.
I was, hey, Daron.
Offensive linemen
would say, hey,
we need 40 barbecue sandwiches.
Yes Sir.
I go downtown, get the
sandwiches, bring them back.
The defensive lineman-- hey,
we need two cases of dip--
Skoal.
I go, fine.
I go to 7-Eleven, trying to
get as much dip as I could,
take it back.
I slept at Arrowhead
for six months.
I got a twin blowup mattress.
And I just wanted
to be the first face
that Herm Edwards saw when he
walked into the office 4:30
every morning.
I was right there.
And I was the last face he
saw when he left at 11:00 PM.
ASHLEY CHANG: And how did you
decide to give up law school?
And I'm sure--
that life for this?
DARON ROBERTS: I had a
professor, David Wilkins,
who was a really
great mentor of mine.
I'm talking with him about the
decision, and he says, listen.
When you get your diploma,
what you won't find on it
is an expiration date.
He said, I'm just going to
take a wild gamble here and say
that when you leave the
NFL, there will still
be legal problems going on.
So if you want to
practice, you can.
He said, let me ask you this.
How rare is this
opportunity for you?
So how many times
will NFL teams allow
you to become a coaching intern
or a training camp intern?
And so for me, I just thought
that with every opportunity
that I get, I think
to myself, OK.
One, does it kind of
flow with my purpose?
And that was an easy check.
And then how rare is it?
Will this come around or
something like it soon?
And if the answer is no
to that, I'm taking it now
and then just adjust from there.
ASHLEY CHANG: So tell us
more about that first year--
the good, the bad.
DARON ROBERTS: Yeah,
coaches wouldn't
talk to me for two weeks.
I had all these coaches on staff
who were former NFL players,
and they had paid their dues.
And they got this dude who
hasn't coached or played
in college just around in
the corner in a hoodie.
And they're like, what the hell?
Who is this guy?
Why did you bring him on?
But they sort of
warmed up a little bit.
First game we play at
Houston, a part of my job
is to make copies.
So I make a copy of the plane
manifest for the flight.
And I see Daron
Roberts, seat 40D.
ASHLEY CHANG: There you go.
DARON ROBERTS: I'm
like, bam, bam, bam.
This is on a Thursday.
Friday, chief of staff--
hey.
Get all the manifests.
Throw them away.
Here's the actual manifest.
We had to make some changes.
40D-- no Daron Roberts.
So someone in the organization
had yanked my name.
They thought that I had
not paid my dues yet--
a pretty high up person
in the organization.
So I said, screw it.
I bought a Southwest flight from
Kansas City, Missouri to Hobby.
I land in Houston.
I know where the team hotel
is that Saturday Night.
I'm the first person
on the team to get off.
Herm walks in, and he's
like, dude, this guy.
He was like, what are you doing?
He's like, were
you on the flight?
I was like, no, I took a flight.
Hey, listen.
I don't want to be in the way.
I'm just going to sit
in the back of the room.
If you need me-- he's like, we
probably won't need you, Daron.
But just stay out of the way.
Cool.
Special teams coach--
he's like, hey.
What are you doing?
I was like, hey,
I took a flight.
ASHLEY CHANG: Surprise.
DARON ROBERTS: He's like, hey.
I could use you
tomorrow, because--
we had a lot of new players.
And I need to be
able to find them
when we go punt or
kick off, so could you
help me wrangle players?
I'm like, I could, but
don't have any credentials.
Can you kinda--
ASHLEY CHANG: Yeah.
DARON ROBERTS: He's like,
let me do something.
By midnight, I had credentials.
By kickoff, I'm on the
sideline, and I'm in.
And so I was on the flight
from that point forward.
But I think the
point is, you really
have to barge your way
in, in a diplomatic way,
in a non-creepy way-- which
in retrospect, it probably
was creepy.
So you have to be
somewhat creepy,
but kind of find this balance.
I don't know.
I don't have a nice--
ASHLEY CHANG:
Creepy factor scale?
DARON ROBERTS:
Creepy factor, right?
But I think it's so easy for
us to send emails and think
that we've done the due
diligence like the email is
enough.
And you need physical
presence to separate yourself
from all the other
folks who are trying
to get into this position.
ASHLEY CHANG: Today, we want
to talk about risk-taking
and certainly your story.
Do you have tips for
actionable things
that folks listening and
Googlers here can take back
to say, I have this inkling.
I'd really like to do this.
How can I get from
there to something
that could be my life style?
DARON ROBERTS: So there's
some really good research--
the Ikea effect.
So who's shopped at Ikea?
OK.
We've all done it, right?
You walk in, and you smell
those weird meatballs.
And you're walking around--
ASHLEY CHANG: You
don't like meatballs?
DARON ROBERTS: It's kind of odd.
It's weird.
Anyway, they're
like halfway cooked.
ASHLEY CHANG: I don't
know what you're saying.
DARON ROBERTS: So everything
looks so pristine,
and you're like, oh, everything
can go into my apartment.
I'll pick that desk.
You get the box,
and you go home.
And you realize you
don't have any tools.
You have never
assembled anything
since like third grade--
building the volcano
that doesn't go off.
And you build this thing,
and it's a little wobbly.
And one of the drawers
doesn't really pull out.
But it's yours,
and you built it.
We're finding that
this Ikea effect--
and think about it sunk cost.
People think about
the fact that they've
dumped so much time and effort
into one course of action.
They use that experience
and that ownership
to then talk themselves out
of taking the risk, right?
Because I've worked at
Google for eight years,
and I started here,
and now I'm there.
I'm not going to take a chance
and now become a chef, right?
What we've found
is the way to get
past that is to expose
yourself to rejection.
So I'm going to challenge you to
put yourself in positions where
people are telling you no, OK?
Here's another technique--
a rejection resume.
You should write this down.
Write this down or
tweet it to yourself
or email it to
yourself or something.
ASHLEY CHANG: We have
many, many, many--
DARON ROBERTS: Many forms.
Take your resume,
and under education,
list all of the schools
you didn't get into.
Work experience-- every
job you did not get.
Go all the way down.
For awards and
distinctions-- all the
awards and honors
that you didn't get.
Take it, and then send it
to all of your friends.
All right?
So I do some trainings
with corporations.
And I'll have the CEO or
CFO do this and then ask
her to send it out.
At first, they
don't want to do it.
And then they do it, and
then they send it out.
And it helps to humanize
them in the organization.
So someone's like, oh, I didn't
get into Berkeley either.
That's great.
I got turned down for
that 30 for 30 too, right?
So I think building this
comfort level with rejection
and getting the no
helps, because you
will document all of your big
nos in life and then realize,
I'm still alive.
I'm OK.
And if I get a subsequent
no from taking a risk,
I'm going to survive, because
look at all the things
that I've been
able to withstand.
So really going
through and cataloging
and being very
intentional about,
hey, when are the
times that I've gotten
turned down or didn't get
the big thing that I wanted
and comparing that to, I'm
still in a good position.
Let me take that as confidence
to go ahead and take more risk.
So in my class,
my students-- they
go on rejection challenges.
So partners-- you have
to go to Starbucks
and ask for a free drink.
Your partner videotapes you.
And I had them do a pre
write up and a post write up.
And then we also take some
risk-seeking scores, right?
And they are so afraid--
even the partner.
Like, we've got the footage.
ASHLEY CHANG: Can I
have a free drink?
DARON ROBERTS: The partner
who's not even getting rejected
is shaking back there.
We take all the footage, and
then we splice it together.
And I show it to
everyone in the class,
and that's usually a
pretty interesting day.
But they go in, they get the
no and a macchiato, right?
You can hear them trembling
and their voice trembling.
And then you have these great
papers being written where they
say, it wasn't so bad, right?
Beforehand, I thought
this was going
to be the worst experience
on the face of the planet.
I got the no.
It wasn't so bad.
I think I'm even willing to take
a bigger risk in the future.
So we're really doing a
lot of research around,
can we help to build
your rejection immunity
by exposing you to new
strains of rejection?
ASHLEY CHANG: Great.
And so we're talking about you
as a lecturer and as a teacher
now, right?
You were an NFL coach,
and you moved on
to many different teams.
And then you pivoted
again, right?
So you went from
coaching in the NFL,
which was another
one of your dreams--
amazing work.
And then how did you
decide, OK, time to pivot.
Let me take another risk.
Let me teach.
DARON ROBERTS: Yeah.
So that's all Dylan Roberts.
So I was in Cleveland.
Is anyone here from
Cleveland, before I
start making disparaging--
this goes out to the
world, doesn't it?
ASHLEY CHANG: It's going to
be recorded today, Daron.
DARON ROBERTS: I
know, I know, I know.
So there's this place
called Cleveland.
So we get to
Cleveland in 2013 we
went 4 and 12, which,
as you'll know,
is not uncommon for
the Cleveland Browns.
It was actually a
pretty damn good year.
Unfortunately, the owner didn't
agree with that assessment.
And we play at Pittsburgh,
we fly back into Cleveland
the last game of the season.
I get a text from the
owner's assistant that says,
8:00 AM staff meeting.
So we wake up and
go into the office.
And the owner walks,
and he says, hey.
Really appreciate all
of your contributions.
You're all fired.
Good luck.
So I go home, and
I'm scrambling eggs.
And my son walks in, and
he's tugging on my shirt.
So I'm scrambling eggs,
thinking about where
is the next NFL city, and
he's tugging on my shirt.
I'm like, what's up man?
You eat breakfast?
I'm like, yes.
Scramble, scramble, scramble.
Tug, tug.
I'm like, what, dude?
You eat breakfast?
so I turned to my wife.
I said, Hilary, we are paying
a lot of money for this kid
to go to a private school.
Is it too late to get a refund?
I don't see the--
something's not working.
My wife, raised on
a ranch in Kansas,
she said, well, let
me ask you a question.
When was the last time you
had breakfast with Dylan?
ASHLEY CHANG: Oh, he's
never seen you eat?
DARON ROBERTS: He'd seen me eat.
And I'm like, oh, yeah.
I could not pinpoint
the time, right?
So I have a breakdown.
Eggs are burning, you've
got alarms going off.
And just the irony for me was
that I had spent all of my time
with other people's sons, and
my own son didn't know me.
He was legitimately surprised
to see me with scrambled eggs,
and that was a problem.
So I decided to
take a sabbatical.
Side note-- if you
ever take a sabbatical,
the equation is, take the
time you think, and it's 5x.
OK?
You're like, oh, I'm just
going to be gone for a year,
and then I'll come back.
Four years later, I'm still
on sabbatical from coaching.
But it's been great.
I went back to teach at UT
some leadership classes.
The Ray Rice episode unfolds.
And I take this proposal
to our president for us
to create a center for sports
leadership and innovation--
to be more
intentional around how
we teach athletes
to become leaders,
to manage their finances.
And that was in 2014.
And I present the proposal.
And he's like, OK,
you're going to run it.
I said, I'm on sabbatical, so
I'm kind of like here, but not.
He's like, no,
you're running it.
And December 2014, we launched.
So we've been at
it for four years.
It's been very, very exciting.
I teach a class to
freshmen athletes at UT.
And we start with Brene Brown's
work around vulnerability
and empathy, migrate over into
Angela Duckworth and "Grit"
and Carol Dweck and "Mindset."
We have our failure
management sequence
where they go and do all these
rejection challenges, and then
end with the leadership
and financial management.
ASHLEY CHANG: And
how many students
have gone through this program?
DARON ROBERTS: So
I've had 850 students.
The great thing about the
class, I think Ashley,
is that half of the class is
comprised of student athletes,
half are non-athletes.
So you have these
two worlds colliding.
You've got the receiver on
the football team sitting down
with this computer CS major.
And one of the first things I
do on the first day of class--
I'll have the computer
science major come up
and put her schedule
down on the board,
and I'll have the football
player come up and do the same.
And you'll see football player--
5:00 AM, work out, breakfast,
shower, classes, lunch,
practice, tape, get to
bed at 10:00, 11:00.
The coder-- the coder's been
up from like 11:00 to 3:00
working on code, sleeps
to 10:00, goes to class,
eats something around
5:00, and back to coding.
And so I say, look.
The football player thinks,
oh, we have it so tough.
We have so much time that
we're putting into our craft.
I said, you've got folks
who are coders in training.
They are spending as much if
not more time than you are.
They just don't have
110,000 people cheering them
on on Saturdays.
So you're both putting a
lot of time into your craft.
Let's find ways to kind of
bridge the gap between student
athletes and non-athletes.
So it's been fun.
They keep me young.
ASHLEY CHANG: So this pivot
was more so unexpected,
but it's something that seems
to be very fulfilling, right?
DARON ROBERTS: Yeah.
I think my life has now been--
I'm trying to find
ways to expand
the world views of athletes.
So football players,
for example--
I tell them, you
are mathematicians.
For a quarterback to
throw a ball 45 yards
to avoid two defenders over
the back shoulder of a person
who's running a 4.3 40 down
a sideline with the wind
blowing 10 miles
out of the west--
that kind of precision.
That is very complex math.
Take that and translate it
over into your algebra class.
And they see these worlds as
being two separate spheres.
And everything
that we're doing is
trying to break down
these barriers to say,
when you give the speech at
halftime that helps your team
to come back from a deficit,
that's crisis management.
That has an application
in the private sector.
Don't see it as, oh--
ASHLEY CHANG: This
is just sports,
and this is what I would
need to do outside of that.
DARON ROBERTS: Yeah, exactly.
So let's bring those
lessons in any sport,
really, and translate those
over into life away from sports.
ASHLEY CHANG: Sure.
Can you talk about your
story about how Kevin Durant
fits in all of this?
DARON ROBERTS: Yeah.
So Kevin Durant spent one year
at the University of Texas,
was one and done, and has such
an appreciation for that time.
And when you talk
to him, he looks
at that one year sort of as
the calm before the storm--
and was a phenom
out of Maryland.
In 2015, he started
thinking about how
he could have a
better relationship
with the university.
And so we're having
conversations with his agent.
I said, hey.
How about you come to
campus, make a speech?
And he's like,
no, I would rather
do a one on one conversation.
And so we did this
talk, and we just
talked through how
much he loves mom,
which I think is incredible.
He talked about the
fact that he thinks
that there is such a
deficit of love and people
who are willing to be
vulnerable and that he's
trying to help people build
a comfort level with that.
And then he talked
about, hey, I want
to find ways to be more
supportive of what we're doing
on campus for our athletes.
And so he's been a supporter.
He wrote a nice check
to us a few weeks ago.
ASHLEY CHANG: Yeah,
congratulations.
This is January.
DARON ROBERTS: Thank you.
Thank you.
ASHLEY CHANG: It
was a nice check.
It was half a million
dollars that Kevin Durant
donated to the center
that Daron founded.
So big congratulations to Daron.
DARON ROBERTS: Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
And if anyone
wants to match it--
PayPal, Venmo, whatever.
ASHLEY CHANG: Any takers?
Anybody?
Just raise your hand.
DARON ROBERTS: We got it all.
ASHLEY CHANG: I think there
was a hand back there, right?
DARON ROBERTS: Yes.
I got the little Stripe thing.
So he has been great.
And we've been able to really
reach a lot of students,
and we're going to be a
little more ambitious now
with some of our offerings.
And we're moving
into that period
where we're scaling beyond
the University of Texas.
ASHLEY CHANG: Amazing.
Well, I also want to
let you know we'll
have some time for questions.
So if you want to just
line up at the mics--
have a few more
things to ask Daron.
But please also feel comfortable
to ask him anything you want.
Take the risk.
DARON ROBERTS: Take the risk.
Take the plunge.
ASHLEY CHANG: Daron, OK.
Now, we talked about Durant.
Now, our other favorite
topic-- donuts, right?
What is with you
and donuts, and what
is with this donut council?
DARON ROBERTS: So
I realized that I
need to be very intentional
about spending time
with my family.
And I think a lot of
people say, oh, I'll
spend more time with my family,
and then that's on a Sunday.
And then you get to
Saturday, and you
think, oh, I haven't spent any
time with my family, right?
So I went into Google
Calendar, and--
ASHLEY CHANG: We haven't
even talked about it.
This is great.
We should have you come back.
Are you free next week?
DARON ROBERTS: Yeah, of course.
Just kind of up the temperature
level a little bit outside.
So my family's color
code is orange.
And we have every Saturday,
7:30, I take the kids,
and we go to a different
donut shop in Austin.
ASHLEY CHANG: And you
said there were how many?
DARON ROBERTS: There are 38.
ASHLEY CHANG: Is that
more than New York?
DARON ROBERTS: It's crazy.
It's crazy.
And what's happened-- this has
been going on for four years.
My mom does embroidery,
so we've got T-shirts.
We walk in, and people are
like, oh, Donut Council.
Hey.
Comp you a few donuts,
be sure to post.
ASHLEY CHANG: That's how
you ask for free things.
Just wear the shirt.
DARON ROBERTS: Yeah.
And now it's gotten
to the point where
my kids are kind of becoming
snobs in a sense of--
my daughter last
week, we were a place.
She goes, you know, cinnamon
rolls here are a bit dry.
ASHLEY CHANG: And
which daughter is this?
How old is she.
DARON ROBERTS: Sydney.
Sydney's five.
I'm like, Sydney, you're five.
Just eat the damn thing.
ASHLEY CHANG: But
Dad, it's not--
DARON ROBERTS: She's
like, it's not as moist.
This donut hole they have--
just eat.
Now I'm spending
a small mortgage.
It started out, oh, half
a dozen donut holes here.
Have fun.
People want bear claws
and chocolate sprinkles.
ASHLEY CHANG: Well, and it start
off with how many, and now--
DARON ROBERTS: So yeah.
It started off with three.
Now we have five.
ASHLEY CHANG: Congratulations.
I know your youngest is
seven months, rights?
DARON ROBERTS:
[INAUDIBLE] seven months,
and he's just trying to
get some of the residue
from the donut hole.
He's just kind of
licking himself.
But it's also a great time for--
I get back with him around
11:00 so my wife can just go
and be childless for a while.
She works for a nonprofit
and also helps with kids,
and so it's good to kind
of give her some space.
But we're at it for four
years, and it's been fun.
So if anyone wants to donate
to the Donut Council--
ASHLEY CHANG: Half
a million dollars?
DARON ROBERTS: Half
a million dollars
will go a hell of a long way.
ASHLEY CHANG: How many
donuts can you eat?
Maybe with the bear
claws it'd be less.
DARON ROBERTS: Yeah,
yeah, with the bear claws.
So now we're actually thinking--
my oldest wants to make a
pivot to breakfast tacos.
ASHLEY CHANG: So you got to
have new embroidered T-shirts
from grandma.
DARON ROBERTS: We have bylaws.
I have veto authority.
I'm one of the
permanent members.
ASHLEY CHANG: Self-appointed.
DARON ROBERTS: Yeah,
self-appointed.
I'm not sure how
I feel about it.
I mean, we are in
Austin, Texas, right?
So there's a breakfast
taco on every corner,
but it kind of seems--
ASHLEY CHANG: It's a
little different, right?
DARON ROBERTS: It's
a little different.
It's not quite so pure.
ASHLEY CHANG: It's
not quite donuts.
DARON ROBERTS: Yeah.
So it's been a great way to
spend time with the kids.
It'll be fun, because my
son was talking about, oh,
when I have kids, I want
to do the same thing.
So it'll be neat to see
the grandkids doing that.
ASHLEY CHANG: So
the coolest part
for me hearing about
the Donut Council--
and why I wanted to talk about
it today-- is it's not just
go eat donuts with Dad.
You talk about real lessons.
Can you share a
little bit of that?
DARON ROBERTS: Yeah.
So we talk through
current events.
I usually pick
one current event,
and then I'll pick
one character trait.
And so a couple of weeks
ago, it was gratitude.
And we talked about the
value of saying thank you.
And I'll have them
kind of think about,
hey, when was the last
time you said thank you?
Sydney-- you could tell Sydney
kind of runs the house--
Sidney said she got an extra
slice of pizza at school,
and she told the lady at
the cafeteria thank you.
I was like, well, how did
you get an extra slice?
She goes, oh, well, she knows
I really like this cheese
that they don't normally have,
and she gave me an extra one.
ASHLEY CHANG: It's not dry.
DARON ROBERTS: It's not dry.
She's very particular
about her food.
And I said, well, how
do you think she felt?
She goes, she gave me
a big smile, right?
So we talk about how there
are these things called
soft skills that people talk
about that's completely off.
They're hard.
And these are the
skills that will
get you fired,
hired, governments
fall, countries fall--
like just truth and integrity.
So they're very important,
and they're hard.
And we have to be very
intentional about talking
about them.
Now they have their own topics.
They're starting to bring them.
Hey, can we talk about
movies and how we
can get more time on the iPad?
I'm like, no, it doesn't
really fit in with the scheme.
ASHLEY CHANG: Veto power.
DARON ROBERTS: Veto
power, done, right?
ASHLEY CHANG: Not a soft skill.
DARON ROBERTS: Yeah,
not a soft skill.
It doesn't fit.
So it's been a blast.
ASHLEY CHANG: You are
teaching students and athletes
how to take risks.
Are you starting to teach
that to your children?
And if so, how are
you doing that?
DARON ROBERTS:
Yeah, so I'm going
to start this year
actually to kind of going
through the rejection resume.
I going to start
broadcasting when I get
turned down from things.
So I've been going
through a two week cycle
with the Harvard
Business Review pitching
them this article about Super
Bowl winning coaches and focus
and how CEOs can
do the same thing.
It got so close, and she
finally was like, no.
Right?
Well, I took a
screenshot of the email.
I thought, I need to just
put this out on social media
without her information
and say, I got turned down
by Harvard Business Review.
But you know what?
It just helps me.
I think the thing with rejection
is you can't take it personal,
but you have to make it
personal in the sense of I
have to dissect
the entire process.
Did I give her enough time?
Did I really flesh
out the proposal?
Could it have been
more succinct?
And then use that
for round number two.
So with them, we've been
talking about entrepreneurship
in our home.
And so my kids
said, hey, you know
how you stuff all
those Christmas cards?
We want to start a business
where people will send
their unstuffed cards to us.
ASHLEY CHANG: I'll
send you mine.
DARON ROBERTS: Right?
I've got a legion of hands.
And we'll stuff it for
them and mail them off.
I thought, that's pretty good.
So my wife and I have
talked about having
some sort of
entrepreneurial theme
this year where we help them
get something off the ground.
ASHLEY CHANG: Great.
Well, we can't wait to
see what you do next
and what your kids-- especially
Sydney-- what she does then.
DARON ROBERTS: Watch
out for Sydney.
ASHLEY CHANG: I think
we have a question.
AUDIENCE: Hey there.
So I have a thought
that I haven't fully
thought through
yet and just wanted
to see if maybe something
you've thought about.
But how do you address
a person or whatever
that's acting like a
person who is risk-averse,
but perhaps their risk aversion
comes from a place of needing
to be perfect?
When we talk about
kids, when we grew up,
we talked about
practice makes perfect.
Now I make a deliberate
attempt to tell my daughter,
practice makes progress,
but I feel like a lot of us
were raised to think about
being really perfect.
And I feel like when
I think about myself,
that I'm very risk-averse.
But I wonder if a lot
of my risk aversion
comes from this
psychology of being
raised to try to be perfect.
I don't know if that's
something that you've--
DARON ROBERTS:
What was your name?
AUDIENCE: [? Katie. ?]
DARON ROBERTS:
[? Katie. ?] First thing--
I'm going to steal that
practice makes progress.
So if you see it
in another form,
then know I've just
taken it from you.
AUDIENCE: It's yours.
DARON ROBERTS: Secondly,
I was at Amazon last week,
and one of their 14--
hope this is OK.
One of their 14
leadership principles
is a bias for action, and I've
adopted this massive action
theme for the year.
I deal with 300 freshmen a year.
And the helicopter
parent phenomenon
is a very real thing,
where they land
at the University
of Texas, and It's
got to be a 4.0, highest
honors, president of this club,
in the right dorm.
The color of the bed
sheets have to be perfect.
Everything has to be perfected.
So I'm constantly talking
with them about imperfections
and also trying to get
them to favor action.
And I'll say, listen.
All you want is more data.
So if you wait to build this
thing until you have it all--
what you think--
perfectly prepared,
you've kept yourself from
collecting the data that you
would have gotten if you
would have just thrown
a beta version out there.
And so I think we
do feel like-- and I
think it's sort of this
Instagram culture of I
need the right filter, and
the lighting, and the angle,
and then I'm going to post.
We've taken that approach and
sort of translated it over
into our professional lives.
And I'm a big believer in
just throw something out
there, get the feedback,
go for version two.
Because I think that's
holding us back.
We have ten year projects
that could have been two year
projects, because
we haven't been
willing to put something
into the marketplace
and just let the market
speak for itself.
So it's a real thing.
I think that the more
that we can just say this
doesn't have to be
completed when I let go,
that I'm going to take that data
and use it to make it better.
I think you have a good point.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Daron.
Thanks for coming.
DARON ROBERTS: Yeah, thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious
about your choice
to get into coaching versus
something that might have been
a more natural fit with
your Harvard Law background
like front office type work--
if the goal was to
do something really
far outside your
wheelhouse or if you did
consider that, and that
wasn't where the passion was.
DARON ROBERTS: Yeah.
And it's interesting
you say that.
Your name again?
AUDIENCE: Todd.
DARON ROBERTS: Todd.
It is interesting you
say that, because, Todd,
I had the coaches
on my staff say
when I first walked
into Kansas City,
oh, you should go the GM track.
You'd be a better suited GM.
I liked the challenge
of starting something--
I played in high
school, like I said,
but I didn't have any
coaching knowledge, right?
And I liked the challenge of
having to learn a new code.
It's a language.
That was more exciting
for me than sort
of doing something that
resembled a bit of what
I had invested three years.
I'm constantly looking for
ways to stay in over my head,
and I thought that the GM
track made too much sense.
I really wanted to stretch my
mind in a different direction.
And I tell you what.
When you have 25, 26-year-old
men who are 6'5", 240 pounds,
running 3.38 40s, flat-footed
jumping 46 inches,
and you have to tell them the
route to run on a certain play,
it takes a lot of courage to
look up at this guy and say,
this is what you need to do.
And I knew that was going to
stretch me more than the office
side of the job.
And the last point
is what's ironic--
it's made me a better teacher.
Dealing with athletes for
seven years has helped me,
I think, to be a fairly good
teacher in the classroom.
So it was a thought, but
then I sort of dismissed it
and went for coaching.
ASHLEY CHANG: Thanks, Todd.
AUDIENCE: My name's Corey.
I got a comment and a question.
So if you're ever in Atlanta,
check out Sublime Donuts--
best donuts in the city.
ASHLEY CHANG: Oh, I would agree.
A few of us were just there.
DARON ROBERTS: You didn't call?
Thanks.
ASHLEY CHANG: Look, you're
getting me in trouble.
Let's move on to the question.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: You
mentioned this idea
of when you were talking about
the illustration of the CS
student and the athlete
and these two worlds
combining of sports
and the outside world.
I feel like we're in
a place where there's
very interesting
things happening
with sports technology and
those two fields going together.
So I'm wondering if you've seen
anything happen on UT campus
or other campuses or
your program is working
with any programs
to not only get
the technology into
the athlete's hands
to have them using it on
the field or in practice,
but also teaching them
about the technology
so they can get
interested in it and maybe
change it for the better
to help future athletes.
DARON ROBERTS: Yes.
So Corey, great first great tip
on the sublime, and then great
question.
So actually, in the fall,
we're unveiling a sports
entrepreneurship sequence
at the business school.
So we're going to have 20
athletes, 20 non-athletes,
and they will start at
ideation all the way
to putting the thing into
the marketplace-- a year
long course.
And we'll bring in
sports entrepreneurs
to expose them to this thing
that we call entrepreneurship.
I think you're spot
on, because it's
been relatively recent that
people have kind of looked
around and said, wait.
Instead of waiting for
the data to come back,
we can just use the on the
field data from practice
and from training
camps to inform
the way that we build products.
And you actually have a
couple of athletic departments
that are considering
building in-house incubators.
So you see this with the 76ers,
for example, where they're just
saying, let's just
bring this in-house,
because we have world
class athletes to get
good feedback from.
Let's use this
setting as a space
where we can ideate and
then test out new concepts.
So I think over
the next few years
that this concept will
really, really take off.
Thank you, Corey.
That was good.
ASHLEY CHANG:
Let's go over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Daron.
My name is Veronica,
and I am seeing
in my field of expertise,
which is employment law, that
at the higher levels
of corporate America,
especially when you're
dealing with C-suite folks
and the leaders in the
companies, that the soft skills
that you alluded to
earlier directly contribute
to the breakdown and meltdown
of workplace relationships.
So in your talks and your
trainings with those leaders,
what kind of response are you
getting from those leaders
when you talk to them about
skills like vulnerability?
DARON ROBERTS: So at
first, they walk in,
and its HR has put
this thing together.
And they've got to go get
real mushy for an hour, right?
So they don't want to be there.
And then we really--
especially with
vulnerability-- first,
I'll show them the research
that says, for managers
who score high on the
vulnerability scale,
their teams produce
more all the things
you care about--
revenue and shareholder.
All of those measures go up.
And it's counter-intuitive,
but the reason
is the team members say, oh,
if she has the confidence
to be vulnerable-- and there
are some limits, right?
But to be vulnerable-- it
creates this safe space,
and they feel more comfortable.
And they actually produce
more and better products
and ideas and concepts.
So I first have to
get them to buy in
that there's this
very real bottom line
benefit to being and using
vulnerability and empathy.
And then I use that hook
to them say, hey, listen.
It's also just good as a human.
Empathy-- the ability to take
the perspective of someone
else.
If there is anything
that's in short supply
right now in our
country or in the world,
it's got to be empathy.
Because we're all, we
know the right answers,
we know what everyone
should be doing.
It's a black white.
It's a very binary world
that a lot of us live in.
But to be able to stop and say,
I'm not from the same hometown.
We're not the same
race or religion.
But I can see how
she would arrive
at this feeling or conclusion.
I think that's important.
It's an uphill battle, though.
I think, especially
in corporate America,
vulnerability and empathy are
tough sells, but we're working.
ASHLEY CHANG: So we'll
take one last question,
and then you can come and ask
Daron a few more afterwards.
Please.
AUDIENCE: My name's Zach.
I'm curious.
In the two pivots that
happened, they kind of
came at natural points,
I would say, as far
as you graduated, and then--
maybe unnatural-- but you
were fired or you were let go.
I'm curious.
Outside of that, how often
do you kind of re-evaluate
where you are, whether
there's something
else you could be doing that
would expand your impact?
And moreover, you've done a
bunch of different things.
You've coached a group of, say,
10 guys in your receiver group
or whatever, and now you're
directing this big thing.
How do you compare
those different options
and evaluate impact in
all these different ways.
DARON ROBERTS: Man, Zach.
You just got right
to the heart of it.
ASHLEY CHANG: Maybe we should
have done this question first.
DARON ROBERTS: Yeah, yeah.
That's the process.
Right now, this is where I am.
So I talked about staying
in over your head.
I am constantly thinking now,
am I challenging myself enough?
If I get comfortable,
it gets a little--
I'm on edge, and I feel like I
may be getting to that point,
right?
I'm also at the point where
I have determined for me
that my life needs to
consist of writing, speaking,
and teaching.
And if I think about the
commonality between coaching
and what I do in the classroom,
it's the teaching piece.
That's the common thread.
So now that I've identified
that subset of what I need,
I'm going to filter or
any opportunity that
comes across my plate
through those three.
It needs to go three for three.
I'm going to be 40.
I can't go two for three.
I need a three for three set up.
But I even don't
know if I'm really
challenging myself
enough right now,
so I'm actively
thinking about that.
And if you have some answers
for me, I will take them.
I'll pay you for them.
But I think it's a
question that people
who want to be intentional
about their lives--
they're constantly
asking that question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DARON ROBERTS:
Thank you for that.
Thank you.
ASHLEY CHANG: Well,
Daron, thank you
so much for spending time
with us today and sharing
your story.
DARON ROBERTS: Thank you.
ASHLEY CHANG: I have
one quick question.
It has to be really quick.
Super Bowl Sunday--
DARON ROBERTS: Oh, lord.
ASHLEY CHANG: --thoughts?
DARON ROBERTS: Eagles by three.
[APPLAUSE]